hey 42 here science has long studied how
animals talk to one another they may not
have language like you and I were almost
every animal on the planet has some form
of communication system sometimes these
can be simple like the bark of a dog or
extremely complex like the sonar waves
of a dolphin
seriously dolphins are better
communicators than most humans
scientists have found that dolphins can
actually send a complete image via sonar
so if Terry the dolphin likes to look of
a certain fish he can actually send an
accurate photo of that fish to his mate
Steve de dolphin so Steve can come and
help Terry to catch it this is the
biological equivalent of human sending
each other Holograms which we can't even
do yet so basically dolphins are the
omnipotent master race and we have
unknowingly been living on their planet
for millions of years but that's enough
about our evil dolphin overlords what
about other fishy communication systems
how about the humble herring well
herring are quite simply the undisputed
Nobel Prize winners of underwater
communication because they use farts to
talk to each other speaking of Nobel
Prizes the fellow who discovered this
dr. Bob Bhatia the Scottish Association
for marine science won the igg Nobel
Prize an award for research that first
makes people laugh and then makes people
think for his fish fart research dr.
Bhatti and two of his colleagues in
Canada became enthralled by Haring farts
when they noticed that small gas bubbles
are rapidly released from the rear of
herrings
every night so obviously they
immediately dropped all their actual
research and set of round-the-clock
infrared video cameras and underwater
microphones to monitor herrings they
noticed that every night when the Sun
Goes Down the herring starts a break
wind and they picked up very
high-pitched raspberry like noises on
the microphones it has one being common
knowledge the herring swim to the
surface to take in huge amounts of air
then they store it in their swim bladder
and then when they see a predator they
reel
one huge bubble of air from their bottom
to attempt to scare off the predator but
through Bob butter and his Canadian
colleagues research we now know that
they do a very similar thing to talk to
the rest of their show what the team
noticed was that the more herring that
are in a tank the more often they fart
indicating that it must be some form of
communication the main way that herrings
use their behind to communicate is to
maintain order within the show when
herring school they do so in a perfect
grid pattern with immaculately measured
spacing in between one another the gap
left between each fish is the typical
distance that a prey will jump away from
the herring when it attempts to eat it
therefore this grid formation allows for
optimal schooling so that's all very
well but how does a school of thousands
of herring organize themselves into an
immaculate grid formation by farting in
each of his faces by releasing noxious
gas from their bottom into the face of
the fish behind them they can precisely
control a distance between each other
and maintain their perfectly spaced grid
it is kind of like constantly farting on
the train so nobody sits next to you but
these aren't your average farts having
rapidly release around 60 short bursts
of gas from their anal dogs over
approximately six seconds the resulting
sound is a single continuous burst of
high-frequency farts scientists have
named these F RTS I'm not kidding which
stands for fast repetitive tick sounds
the benefit of this noise is that most
of a fish can't hear this high-pitched
farting sound but herring can so by only
farting to communicate they are able to
travel in huge schools and remain
relatively undetected by predators in
1994 Sweden almost went to war with
Russia over herring farts the Swedish
military detected an almost metallic
clicking sound underwater
incredibly similar to the noise produced
by Russian submarines Sweden went on
high alert and dispatched military units
to search for intruders within their
waters Sweden even wrote a letter to
Russia demanding them to withdraw their
submarines from their waters at once but
they quickly swept the whole thing under
the rug when a Swedish scientist
discovered that the Sun they recorded
was not enemy submarines but a school of
thousands of farting herrings nature is
weird and sometimes it seems like
evolution has totally lost it it's not
just herring though humans do some
pretty strange stuff too but no matter
how weird you think you are just
remember at least you don't talk out of
your ass unless your name is Donald
Trump thanks for watching normally
government combat obesity with hopeless
advertising campaigns and even taxing
junk food but Japan went the extra mile
and simply made it illegal to be fat do
you ever hear a noise not to bump in the
night per se but a full